my name is Noah green I am the associate
director of education and assessment at
the Explorer's guide to biology
I remember just from a young kid and my
dad took me out and got a one of those
little droppers of just like puddle
water from outside and we looked at it
underneath the microscope and there was
just so many little microorganisms
swimming around in that one little drop
of puddle water and I just it just like
blew my mind I couldn't imagine that
like there was so much life in like a
puddle that I'd just always been like
stomping around and splashing through my
whole life there's just like this whole
Hidden World and not just microbiology
you know not just outside your body but
there's like systems and cells and
everything in every single living
organism once I kind of grasped that
thought I just like had to know more I
need to understand how all of this works
and so that's how science became you
know sort of a passion of mine I
remember learning about
how people are starting to study
cognition and you know the science of
thinking and how you can connect the
physical brain and neurons and things
like that to thoughts and actions it was
it it was just so fascinating I couldn't
I couldn't get it out of my head it was
a whole meta thing of thinking about
thinking I I got that in my brain and it
sort of locked me up and never let me go
so one of the most interesting things I
learned as a neuroscientist was probably
when I started learning about
electrophysiology
and so electrophysiology is the study of
how neurons create signals that they use
to communicate with each other and they
use electricity to do that and as
scientists we can record those signals
so we can go into a live animal brain
and record the live activity of a neuron
I got more involved in doing at first
single cell recordings
I was trying to bring an electrode down
onto a single cell and attach the
electrode to that cell and then be able
to record the activity of that cell and
so I remember the first time that I was
able to do that it took me like two or
three months to even be able to get a
live cell cultured but I remember the
first time I was able to
attach my electrode onto a cell and
record that cell activity I got so
excited that I jumped up out of my chair
knocked my array off of the cell because
I was going to go show my Pi that I had
done it and I was like oh no now I have
to go do it again but that was one of my
favorite moments of electrophysiology
just because it was so much work that
went into this one goal and you finally
get there and you get so excited it was
it was a lot of fun
later in my graduate career I got an
opportunity to do a teaching as research
Fellowship through the Vanderbilt Center
for teaching and it introduced me to
this whole world of the cross between
neuroscience and how people learn in
cognitive psychology and that that
really just just grabbed me I was I was
fascinated by it and so that eventually
led to me starting my own business to do
digital education Consulting and I did
that for about five years and that led
me to a job with the science
communication lab which is where I am
now so one of the things that I love
about working at the Explorers guide to
biology is that we get to work with so
many people who have made these amazing
discoveries and talked to them about
this their science and their discoveries
and and their Journeys not just the
discovery and the science but how it all
happened and that's that's a big part of
what we're trying to convey to the
Learners the people who read our
resources that you know science is a
process and then it's done by people